A popular character, some serious legal
threats, and a glossy Netflix reboot.
Here'sthe real reason the "Adult Wednesday
Addams" series all but disappeared.
Netflix recently premiered a new trailer
for "Wednesday," a TV series produced
and directed by Tim Burton. As its title
suggests, "Wednesday Addams" will focus on
Gomez and Morticia's teenage daughter Wednesday,
portrayed by Jenna Ortega, as its protagonist.
ButNetflix's new series is far from the first
time the character has been expanded upon.
Originating in the "Addams Family" comic
strip from cartoonist Charles Addams,
just like the rest of the Addams Family,
Wednesday Addams has already gone through
numerous incarnations. Lisa Loring was
the first actor to portray Wednesday,
in the 1960s sitcom that marked the first of
many adaptations of its core cast of characters.
Perhaps the most notable actor to appear on-screen
as Wednesday Addams is Christina Ricci, who played
the character in the 1991 "The Addams Family"
film, and its 1993 sequel, "Addams Family Values."
Some viewers might associate the character more
closely with writer and performer Melissa Hunter,
whose recent writing credits include series
like "Santa Clarita Diet" and "She-Hulk:
Attorney at Law." Prior to
her work on those two shows,
Hunter created and starred in a YouTube
web series titled "Adult Wednesday Addams,"
consisting of short scenes of the iconic
"Addams Family" character all grown up.
At the moment, however, "Adult Wednesday Addams"
is no longer available on Hunter's YouTube channel
where it originated. And in an interview with
Buzzfeed, "Adult Wednesday Addams" creator
Melissa Hunter finally revealed what happened to
her YouTube series. As it turns out, Hunter was
compelled to remove the series from her channel
after receiving a cease and desist letter from the
Tee & Charles Addams Foundation, which owns the
"Addams Family" copyright. Hunter told Buzzfeed,
"But, the good news is, I still have the dress."
Understandably, Hunter has
been reluctant to pursue
any avenue that results in legal
action, and explained to Buzzfeed,
While Hunter's web series became the target of a
copyright claim, an adult film parody based on her
work remains online, as do unofficially-uploaded
videos of "Adult Wednesday Addams" episodes.
In an interview with Mike Elder
on his YouTube series Box Angeles,
Hunter described Wednesday Addams as a part
of her childhood identity. Hunter also said
that "Adult Wednesday Addams" was a project she
spearheaded in order to put something out into
the world that was entirely hers. Though
it may be over, past episodes of Hunter's
passion project are hosted on Vimeo, and
still viewable on Hunter's personal website.
For Melissa Hunter and all involved, the
abrupt end of "Adult Wednesday Addams" was
devastating. To make matters worse, even
when she tried to keep her series alive
in the face of imminent cancellation,
the parties involved simply couldn't
make a deal happen. In a Twitter post
from February of 2021, Hunter wrote,
Hunter's tweet, of course, was in response to
the Netflix Twitter account announcing their
new series, "Wednesday." However, Hunter
also made it clear that she wasn't angry,
and was instead happy that Wednesday maintains
a place of pop culture prominence. She tweeted,
There are many reasons to be excited about the
Netflix premiere of "Wednesday." But if you're
hoping for new episodes of Melissa Hunter's "Adult
Wednesday Addams," you're probably out of luck.